de la fumée s'élève dans le ciel de la
capitale
demis et se sont abattues ici tout près
de kiev la russie affirme avoir détruit
la plus grande réserve de carburant de
l'armée ukrainienne en ce moment
dans la première phase de notre
opération militaire dit ce général russe
nous avons atteint nos objectifs
s'opposent bonheur les capacités de
combat des forces ukrainiennes ont été
réduites nous souhaitons maintenant
réaliser notre objectif principal la
libération du donbass
cette région de l'est de l'ukraine est
convoité par moscou depuis des années
devant un parterre de journalistes
c'est officiel du kremlin prétendent
qu'ils n'ont jamais voulu s'emparer de
kiev où ou d'autres grandes villes oui
et ni aux premiers rôles et stumm
pourtant car qu'eva été la cible de
bombardements encore aujourd'hui des
mario paul est en grande partie détruite
parmi les centaines de personnes qui
s'étaient réfugiées dans le théâtre
bombardé la semaine dernière au moins
300 sont mortes a annoncé la mairie
l'entrée de cet abri est toujours bloqué
par des débris
selon des informations reçues par les
nations unies il y a bel et bien des
fosses communes dans la ville assiégée
de mario paul
l'une d'entre elles contiendraient
environ 200 corps les résidents
commencent aussi à manquer d'eau et de
nourriture nous allons en lien avec la
turquie et avec la grèce lancé une
opération humanitaire pour évacuer tout
ce toutes celles et ceux qui souhaitent
quitter marioupol
cela fait trente jours un mois dit le
président zelensky taquet il dit aux
russes qu'il est nécessaire de chercher
la paix qu'ils ne savent pas ce qui les
attend tellement
se targue d'ailleurs d'avoir coulé un
navire de transport de troupes russes
ancrés dans le port de berriane qu en
mer d'azov malgré une domination sur
papier moscou se heurte toujours à une
résistance aussi déterminé qu'inattendue
ici sébastien et desrosiers radio canada
morrell